hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new exclusive at Collider interview this
is for a movie that I'm really excited
about you both know I loved this at
Sundance 2019 we spoke a little there
but I'm very happy right now
to reconnect with Hannah pearl and
gentle ik of before you know it I have
so many questions about just the journey
from Sundance to where you guys are
right now but I was reading the new
press notes and there's a little bit in
it that says that when you two first met
you didn't really I don't know if get
along is the right term but after seeing
this movie and just talking to you guys
it shocks me that there was any point in
your lives where that was the case so
can you tell me about meeting for the
like just in the press no just so
everyone knows we you know what it was
just a comedy of errors as all of us we
met when we were very young in Brooklyn
and we were at a party and Hannah
thought that I was making eyes at her
friend's boyfriend she didn't know that
I was a raging homo and which would have
cleared things up immediately I'm pretty
sure you were in like a SEP you were in
like a bedroom in the apartment they
were rehearsing they were in a band
together
and I have less of an issue with her
flirting with someone who was taken by
my friend and more of an issue with how
disgusting I found him to be almost
certain he will at some point hear one
of these interviews I don't care anyway
once we had established that that was in
fact not what was happening then we got
to talk in and realize that we had
similar sensibilities and that I wanted
to borrow her clothes
I feel like borrowing clothes is usually
the key this sweatshirt is not mine
these pants are mine if you knew how
much clothing I have from my poor sister
who is in New York and has no chance of
getting it back right now it's a problem
she might hate me for it
what would you say out there to somebody
who is a budding filmmaker and dreams of
finding a close collaborator because
going to film school that was one thing
that I really wanted and I thought it
was never going to happen and then luck
of the draw it it was I did I found that
person and it's a special thing so what
would you say to someone who is
concerned they might
find that hmm it's okay if you don't
find it you can find it within yourself
but my advice would be to stay open to
people give them a second chance if at
first you don't connect try try try
again
and also be married to one hard version
of a collaboration I mean ours has
evolved so much over the years that it
was one thing six years ago and is now a
very different thing but the bottom line
is we trust each other and want each
other's opinions on things that's as far
as it goes and sometimes it's a little
more literal but I think working with
people that understand your essence
that you'd want to be in the foxhole
with I think that's the same as finding
a romantic partner yeah find someone who
communicates the same way that you do
when you are crewing up a project is it
ever the the idea that you know I'm just
hiring someone to fill a position or is
an interview for you guys more like
finding someone that kind of fits that
family - yeah it's it's never just well
unless we're in a super bind or we have
to pick someone that the Union gives us
we have to pick them I pick you the only
person I'm 43 but know every every
meeting with every piece of production I
tried to meet with as many of those
people as possible although I left the
hiring of certain roles - department
heads and so making sure that me and my
department heads were on the same page
was very important but yeah it's about
finding people it's all about
communication style for me like can we
understand each other do we see this
story in similar enough way as a kind of
baseline but then are we able to talk
our way through the where we may differ
on that makes sense
did you guys always want to get into
filmmaking storytelling performing or is
there ever a point in your lives where
you said I want to grow up and be like I
don't know a doctor or a lawyer or
something like that I wanted to be in
our visual artists for a while and there
was a year or two where I wanted to be
an entomologist
yeah one painting but was made quickly
apparent to me that I was incredibly bad
at it so I think I also like the idea of
teaching for a while I thought I might
go into academia but that's just part of
the school that I went to they just lead
you to believe that every thought you
have is really worthwhile uh-uh
until I mean similarly until I left for
angelical Church I thought I was gonna
be a biblical scholar for a while but
those were like teenage aspirations that
I thought I thought well if I can't make
it as an actor and a writer then I'll
try something just as easy which is to
be a theologian you have course and so
and I thought that I would be a
comparative religion professor that's
right pinging around the same delusion
oh yeah this all makes a lotta sense it
puts into perspective my my second major
in Hebrew and Judaic Studies that
completely went out the window and I
remember nothing about that we could
party I you know I don't know if the two
are connected but I'm definitely fun at
a party you're fun on birth right I know
I never went on birth right and it is
one of the biggest regrets of my life
did you miss your window I I missed the
window but it was also because you know
I was always working and always wanted
to do something else and it never really
I never had that free block of time that
aligns with that trip you gotta stop and
live your life follow sometimes I feel
like I live my life vicariously through
movies right now which isn't the worst
thing because we were talking before you
travel about sisters who live together
in New York City I feel like you take
that box for me already
that you went through a whole bunch of
drafts with the script so I'm curious
what is the biggest difference between
draft one and the final product Wow
I think it's the biggest difference
between who we were then and who we are
now which is I think we have a level of
self-awareness and emotional
intelligence that we were just beginning
to develop
we started working on the script really
thought we had right I think perhaps a
bigger difference is the fact that we
thought we had it then and didn't and
hopefully have a little bit now and
definitely think that we do that's right
although I think that's just the 20s to
the 30s and then specifically I would
say it just got more honest yeah it was
more of a it was more of a farce and
less personal before I was kind of
surprised it's just I vividly remember
my first viewing and it was a communal
viewing so it was a very loud reaction
in that theatre people were laughing at
all the right moments and just re
watching it I don't know I guess I just
didn't realize the first time around how
powerful the drama isn't it and it works
nice exceptionally well you guys went
through the Sundance lab with this one
how do you get started with that kind of
process because we do have a lot of
viewers and listeners who really want to
make movies and that seems like an
excellent Avenue for someone to get a
feature off the ground yeah the labs are
wonderful I it's yeah it's always funny
recommending them because you're like
you've got to go to Juilliard we lucked
out a lot of a lot of getting into the
lab has to do with timing and we didn't
get in the first time when we were
rejected for the screenwriters lab and
then separately for other labs and our
producer Mallory Schwartz applied with
the same script that we had applied with
months later and I don't lot of work on
to the creative producing labs but that
was after we had a short in the festival
so those after we wrote and produced and
we're in a short film called partners
and they do a really good job of
tracking people who go through the
festival and also when you apply they
really they keep track of repeat apply
persistence counts
uh-huh but they're you know they're very
thoughtful in the selection process and
it's really about curating a group for
that year based on previous years and
and who might fit well together and
their tiny groups so my biggest piece of
advice is don't be discouraged if you
get rejected just keep working on on
whatever you applied with and other
stuff and if the timing feels right
apply again so which lab did you wind up
getting in to with this project so the
first one was the creative producers lab
gotcha then they put me through a mini
workshop in LA for directing and after
that workshop I asked to be considered
for the directing lab which is
invite-only
oh they invite you to apply to it so I
invited them to consider and then we did
that and Jen came out to act in the
scenes so that was the first week where
we also met Judith and then the last
week is the screenwriters lab which we
did together so we want it we wound up
doing all of them but we did them sort
of backwards
we kinda weasel our way in there as long
as it comes out with a finish go away so
you get into a lab does the lab come
with the likelihood of a green light
happening or is that something that has
to manifest along the way it definitely
it helps I think yeah it helps
legitimize the project for sure and
Sundance has their own pool of investors
that they've been cultivating for
programs like catalysts which we also
went through which is a creative
financing forum catalyst women which was
right kind of woman it was the first
year that they did it just for female
LED projects I just like the sound of
creative financing financing is always
the thing that stresses me out the most
the second you put creative at the
beginning of it then I'm a little more
yeah the whole idea is that it is a
give-and-take and that you're looking
for collaborators in your finance ears
and your finance ears are looking for
they need to know what they're looking
for in terms of what they want to get
out of their investment because it's
independent film and you weren't
oftentimes doing it to make a ton of
money so you must be doing it for other
reasons as well and so it's about
identifying those reasons and making
sure that they're aligned with the
filmmakers intent for the film what
about the idea of making this in New
York because having lived in New York I
was just walking around all the time
saying I'm never gonna move to LA I love
it here there's a huge industry here but
then I was encouraged over and over
again to move out here and I am happy
out here but I am always looking for a
reason to go back and highlight the film
industry there so did you ever consider
making movies out here more so I mean I
know you were saying you're out here now
yeah we both live here now and we've
lived here for a while but we met in New
York and both lived there for a long
time okay so not only was the conception
of this story in New York but I think
the version of ourselves that we were
and we started working on it was very
much left the ghost of that is left in
New York and it's a movie about New York
I mean it's it's very much about a
family that's still living in this petri
dish of old-timey you know theater and
Hollywood and in music because the
father won't allow them to step beyond
it and that felt like an inherently New
York climate so when did you guys make
the move out here you met in New York
did you make a couple projects in New
York before go in LA not together no no
right work together I made my first
short film in New York that I wrote and
was in and my friend directed and I did
the same short that I was wrote and was
in and then that's when we started
working on the script for this then I
moved back to LA because I had done my
first couple years of school out here
and at that point it was kind of like
any time one of us was on the other
person's coasts we would dive back into
the script and do another reading that
was like weird this is just the last
reading we're doing before we make the
movie
next week eight years ago and then we
continued to work on our own projects in
New York and LA and got into commercials
which is how we survived Frank
financially financially and also have
financed my short films basically how I
created a miniature film school and then
we made partners and that was the first
thing we actually filmed together
because we wanted to see what it was
like to act together and we loved it so
much that we took the chemistry we found
between those characters and created a
series called disengaged with
super-deluxe
which unfortunately is not on the
internet because the company went under
and so we don't know oh no we're hoping
to have them back up on another platform
soon so people can see you can watch the
pilot currently okay
although aren't the views still up there
it got over a million views but I don't
know if you can see that anymore and a
lot of comments about my hair as I
recall that's not true but you'll never
know cuz this has been taken out it did
have a lot of actually really well
whatever we play a couple in the series
oh yeah you haven't experienced rampant
homophobia until you've gone into the
YouTube comments I'm a queer love story
yeah yeah I mean when you're on our
channel I don't want to tell you about
the comment section but it happens
everywhere and it's just about you know
making sure you're sending the right
message no matter what the reaction is
and hopefully everybody's open to
everything out there going back to what
you guys said about just what happened
with the distribution with that project
did that influence how you handle or
look at some sort of distribution
opportunity for a movie like this
especially coming out of a festival like
Sundance you know what were your
expectations going into that premiere
and then where those expectations met
when you walked away I think I mean we
had a much different experience just by
virtue of our connection to the film I
my expectation
I think were more abstract I was just
excited that people were going to see it
yeah and was trying not to think beyond
that I think Hannah was required to have
a bit more foresight because she
directed the film but I I think as far
as our collective energy at that time it
was like we're so happy we made it we're
so happy people are gonna see it it's
amazing where it's on dance let's see
yeah I think we both tried to really
tell her I didn't anticipate it being
such a long process the we wrapped the
movie and maybe maybe this won't sound
long at all but we wrapped the movie a
year ago yesterday and it's just now
coming out in the 30th comes out the
30th and and I've been we've been doing
festivals all summer and so I've been
going to these different cities trying
to spread word of mouth and establish a
base all over because it's going to be
in a hundred theaters which is something
I definitely didn't anticipate but now
at the end of all of that at the end of
eight months of traveling with the movie
it feels like the real work of promoting
it is just starting oh and that's
hilarious that's insane but but hey
that's that's the deal and we're so
remote so yeah the expectations were
exceeded definitely by the the theatre
account that we have in the fact that we
have a theatrical release and our
distributors have been really
collaborative and wonderful and we've
heard horror stories about people with
their distributors so we were coming
into it with a lot of anxiety and
they've been great I've heard many of
those and also just with the changing
landscape now I am just like sometimes I
lose sleep over the idea of certain
movies not getting theatrical releases
anymore and it's not to knock streaming
services they get movies in front of
more eyes and they might have before but
I just never want to see that window
closed too much for smaller independent
fare and I fear that being the future
yeah well right for the
particular film - I mean it would always
be exciting for one thing I think in
many regards we're a couple of Luddites
so the idea I'd be like we must
physically go to the theater but also
this film I think does does beat - its
heart beats to a rhythm that is very
old-school New York and feels very see
the movie in the theater with pop Garnon
and it's a I think it's like I think
it's good for different generations and
I think it could be a nice opportunity
to hang with your you know the young
folk hanging with the older folk I think
it's a real assay if to me it feels like
a community building movie I can feel
that I think it comes through with the
the core location on its own it's just
like the theater house combo has like a
texture to it that you could feel yeah I
[Music]
also wanted to ask you guys about the
title of the movie that was another
thing that I read that the title changed
I'm always fascinated about finding out
how someone landed on a particular title
especially something like before you
know it it was the stupid happy that was
that on the table which we maintain it's
a great title it's just no longer suited
the movie and we couldn't when we
thought about being asked why stupid
happy we couldn't come up with anything
better than well it's always been called
stupid ass and so we wanted something a
little more tonally appropriate and
before you know it we came up with we
were in a bit of a bind we had to give
them a title and a rapid-fire text
exchange with our producers while we
were going to the festival yeah we were
packing for Sundance oh wow no that's
entry there they're going somewhere the
press release was about to come out
that's right that's right
and so we we had to get them the title
and we picked a B by accident but it did
put us at the top of the press release
which was awesome it's not the first
time it is a double entendre
because it's a line from the film my
cultures character Mike says it when
he's referencing repressing a feeling as
opposed to addressing it and what
happens is before you know and you know
a little faster but also it's literally
what happened before Rachel and Jackie
yeah yeah we felt like it encapsulated
all of the characters journey with
communication and honesty I think that's
a reasonable reason to go with that
title exam or picking a name I've heard
that many times before whether it's it
being at the top of the Sundance list or
even once a movie goes to VOD and you
search the all film menu it's listed
alphabetically you wish I didn't know
what I wish I could unknown but it's in
there now or you need to go with digits
for no reason at all just put like a
zero at the beginning
how has your collaboration developed
over the years especially from first
project to now writer director star
writer star but are you collaborating a
lot while you're actually shooting the
film so yeah we do collaborate while
we're shooting
it's nebulous but in a way that's also
really lived in I mean I think trying to
explain it to people probably sounds way
more abstract than it is but because we
figured out what worked for us over the
course of a decade it was never the same
two things on any given day I think it
was about five year when we made this
short
that's when we realized Hannah's
trajectory was gonna be too direct and
more importantly that she was gonna be
directing this film and that at that
point that informed the way we continued
to write so we had written in a way that
was more looked a lot more like
volleying the work before she'd write
I'd edit and vice versa and then once we
realized she was gonna be at the helm of
the film itself it became easier to just
let her take first passes and start to
structure story and then I would come
and punch in which isn't necessarily how
we both work in other collaborations but
it's just been what works for us and
then on set we're flexible if it's
something
if it feels like something isn't working
I'll gens the first person I turn to hit
me when you're working with some
producers is there ever a scenario on
this where someone raises a red flag
whether it's in the script stage where
it could be a concern or if you want to
be a little more fluid with something on
set and change something on the spot
where someone's like no don't do that it
we can't accommodate it not with this
when our producers were so lovely
Mallory Schwartz started working with us
four years ago five years ago and so
she's she's been there for every
iteration of this movie and our
relationship and our personal
development I'm gonna say she's become
like our child but she's really become
our mother yeah so she she knows I mean
she she knows what my priorities are so
the only time I ever got pushed back was
if if she felt you needed to remind me
of a priority that I had stated that it
seemed like I was forgetting which
really happened cuz I don't forget my
priorities but you know it would be like
you had said that this was important to
you if we if you want to go again on
this or you want to try at a totally
different way it's gonna eat into this
scene that you really wanted to reserve
these hours for and that was that was
the way of working that we established
early on and it was the same with my
line producer it was always like I can
give you that this is what it will cost
you in these other things that you've
already told me are important what were
some of the scenes that you prioritized
I mean even I don't want to spoil
anything for anybody but the ones that
come to mind from the beginning you know
the water in the house the tracking shot
I loved the scene with Mandy speech yeah
I think that's one of the funniest
things in the movie is there any
particular scene that you said to
yourself this is where we should
prioritize our schedule well the the
opening shot we really worked to carve
out the right amount of time so it was
the end of a very long day I think was
our only day of exteriors with the
theater
shut down 13th Street right so that was
stressful and we lay the track we also
had to make adjustments just for
budgetary reasons because I I wanted a
really big I wanted the opening shot to
say like this is a big this is a big
movie so in my mind it was a crane shot
and then you know I talk to my land
producer and she was like that's not
although she did everything to make it
work anyway so we we lay the hundred
feet of track my DP is so giddy he's
lighting the street he's got this condor
down the street and they turned the
light on and like five minutes later the
cops show up because we're keeping
everybody in the other building awake
and so we have to spend another hour
flagging the light and then he has to
adjust all of the lighting on the street
because we had all these plant lights
and all this and by the time we actually
started shooting that scene which is it
I wanted it to be a winner but I'm not
insane I think we talked about this I
also wanted there to be coverage just in
case threw that out it was I was like
this is a winner and we're going to get
it in two takes because we have time
before it's a wonder and a good winner
that establishes the atmosphere of New
York City I love it I happened to be on
set still that day I think out of nerves
I don't know if you had asked me to be
or if I just told you I was going to be
but I was a good news day and I was with
the producers in village just like
sweating sweating with the cans on
because it was it was gonna be the walk
and I want her and then once we got to
our positions we were gonna get
close-ups just you know in case but who
wants a close-up not me these two mugs
that's when you get some of the best
stuff though it's like that that happy
magic that comes out of you know being
restricted with your budget in your time
and everything yeah holding holding yeah
it was funny the things that we planned
for
scenes I anticipated requiring extra
care tended to actually be the easiest
when it came down to shooting them and
if anything it was just the the anxiety
of the preparation that made them take
longer so that's a lesson I'll take away
what are your onset vices like if you
have anxiety or need to like chill out
or just need energy is it I don't know
coffee I was hiding in the office but
not because I'm embarrassed but because
if I buy them and I put them here and
there was a point at which we had Sophia
who's a dear friend of ours who Hannah
had work as her assistant so we could
have her there at one point was
dutifully buying me secret diet dr.
peppers and bringing them to me in paper
bags as if they were like malt liquor
because ok I have to have it I love a
fizzy I love a caffeinated fizzy when I
once said that's my advice and feel like
it makes it better calling it a
caffeinated fizzy for now use Diet Coke
I'm just gonna repeat that yeah up be
fizzy I think I'm just like generally
consumptive like I have I have no idea
what I drink or whatever Oh Sophia's
hand yeah that's true I yeah I basically
just ate whatever wasn't we also had
Hannah I was very proud of this she made
sure that was as green as possible and
that meant trying to eradicate water
bottles which is a problem on a lot of
sense you know you've got like thousands
of these tiny placer days still wasteful
so many but we had gotten all of the
cast and crew
these small edible roll-up water water
these bags they look like Alaska
colostomy colostomy colostomy bags with
a carabiner but the problem is they hold
about a thimble of water so what you
ended up stake was like all of us
running back and forth between these
water jugs like just
that's a pretty good on set gift to give
to make sure everybody I think I did a
water bottle one year and it's nice and
then if you actually hang on to it and
don't lose it on set you are getting
souvenir and then people walk around
with it
although the hats that we made everyone
that said stupid happy well now it's a
collector's item eBay they were also
more red than we anticipated they looked
like to be like a rich fuchsia like a
pink or bust and rose well at least it
was just two words but one of our
friends who's in the cast Alexandre
Schwartz made us a couple of ones with
the correct title very sweetly and now
that it's even more text it looks even
more like make America great because
this before you know it and I tried to
wear it out on a hike the other day and
I kept getting looks and I was like I
must be glowing today and I realized
it's because people thought I was in a
drum pad alright yeah I think I received
a an unnamed movie sent me a bright red
hat summery recently and not wearing
that hat no you mustn't before we have
to wind this down I want to make sure
our viewers get to know you guys a
little bit so just a bunch of random
questions I don't have my list here but
I'm just gonna pull out the one I
remember right now first off what are
you watching right now it could be
anything a new movie a new TV shows
something you're catching up on anything
at all I'll go fast I years I love you
for you yes I'm Pro euphoria very much
so I know it's a polarizing show but I
think it's brilliant and beautiful and I
just re-watched border which is my
favorite film of the last three years
good call
I also love border I just thought for
the first time the new season of fleabag
is mm everything new season of killing
Eve we just started watching the new
season a mind hunter wait
I just love it and I've been watching a
lot of older movies a lot of classics
that I have never seen and a lot of
rom-coms
because I am writing one right now for
Miss Jane fu er I like the sound of that
[Music]
if you guys had to get a movie related
tattoo what would it be and why oh do
you know go ahead I do
I had bacon the egg ranch was super
meaningful to me when I was a teenager
but I was like figuring out that I was
queer and the art in it is I think
really beautiful and unfortunately it
turned into a tattoo that a lot of young
queer theater nerds got but it's
beautiful it's just a face and I've
almost gotten it many times while drunk
but I think I probably would but I also
have a neck so funny girls the movie
that changed my life
I love Barbra Streisand and I have a
gold necklace that says BAE coal instead
of a name and so I had always I'd always
thought about I have some stick and poke
tattoos that say things I thought about
getting big for for Fanny Brice Sailaja
Barbra Streisand
maybe on the other arm mine would
probably just be text it would probably
say like don't cut let's go again right
away the path you're on right now
do either of you have any pets no no no
that's understandable hard earn is today
I want to know what's your pet peeve
actually doing it juvenile do you have
an on-set pet peeve something where if
it happens it gets under your skin
quicker than other things as an actor I
do and it's something she never does
which is why I love working with her
which is she never I mean within reason
of course if it's a long day and you're
worried about time you have to stop
people but when directors cut off an
improv to offer their own funny line oh
that is a spicy nono for me
I cannot I will completely you won't see
it on my face but internally I will
completely take any ounce of respect I
had for you and blow it into the window
understandable yeah this is really
specific to one person that I worship
but my pet peeve became confusing
treating the actors well and with
respect with crossing firm boundary okay
like asking asking me I you know and I
can't do it without adding him just of
what you're getting at but probably
better is better off not chair details I
also when I when I got in the chair in
the morning any kind of like small talk
wandah being very difficult for me
because I would be getting into hair and
makeup and it seemed like I was just
getting into hair and makeup and for any
other person getting into hair and
makeup it would have been fine but I was
like going over the shot list in my mind
trying to take a moment of not speaking
before the day of speaking constantly
again so that became I've actually never
pictured that for someone who is both
acting in a movie and directing it that
makes a lot of sense I'm surprised I
haven't thought about that before it's a
bummer and it wound up becoming like a
peeve with myself also because I was
like why can't I just multitask better
why can't I just hear about your day
right now
and to wrap up right now I love ending
on this question because it makes me
happy what is one thing happening in the
industry or one individual that you
think is changing it for the better yes
I agree with it's a good answer I am so
happy she's in the world it makes me
emotional I feel like the the good guys
are winning when I see the work that
she's making I shouldn't say guys the
good people because I yeah I know that
would probably be the response from a
lot of like-minded people and I think
that's great yeah I couldn't agree more
yeah I agree I agree also with
I think the work that Luca Aguada you
know is doing is is changing the
landscape in a way that I really
appreciate I wholeheartedly agree with
that one as well call me by your name
was my number one of 2017 and Suspiria
was one heck of a ride recently oh my
god I love this very I want to turn on
me I I just can't I can't believe I
don't necessarily call it a turn on but
it's just like between we also have a
horror podcast here called the witching
hour and just between the the witchy
dancing us of that movie and then if you
ever go see climax
oh my those two movies just like still
have my head spinning my response to
that question is typically Jurgis and
Tomas because I think and Ruben Austin
because I think they're darked you
filmmakers but I said yes they are
you're correct they are both men and I
hope that my answer to that and that and
those your honor is this not this ain't
very soon so can you please make a
horror movie
would you ever I would love you okay
that's right up my alley so yeah I don't
know that I I don't know that I would
write a horror movie
very well but I would be very interested
in directing someone else's well-written
horror movie well funny you should say
that I'll tell you about this later but
we have to wrap up this conversation so
I want to say thank you so much for
coming in today about this movie guys
before you know it in theaters a hundred
theaters specifically that's something
else
August 30th do check it out trust me you
are going to enjoy it is there anywhere
on the Internet our viewers can find new
social media websites anything like that
we're both on Instagram that's my my
primary platform the movie has a website
now yes before you know it before you
know what Hanul world
odd how about that Sundance but if you
want to get in touch with us directly
Instagram and before you know it is also
on Instagram if you look up before you
know it film on Instagram get on that
guys go check it out also do not forget
to like and share this
video or the podcast wherever you are
listening or watching and stay tuned
cause we're gonna have more interviews
for you real soon